while the cold war with the soviet union
was a nuclear arms race the cold war
with china is being fought in digital
space
in late august washington restricted
sales of sophisticated ships to china
and russia
the two top silicon valley chip
designers nvidia and advanced micro
devices have been told to limit sales of
their high-end ships known as graphics
processing units or gpus
gpus were originally developed to render
images in video games but are now used
in super computers that recognize speech
and identify objects in photographs
in other words they can be used for
artificial intelligence gathering the
people's daily the mouthpiece of china's
communist party claimed on its twitter
account that the country's facial
recognition system could scan the faces
of china's 1.4 billion citizens in just
one second and by the way this tweet was
in 2018.
nvidia the largest gpu maker by far
confirmed that the u.s federal
government now requires the company to
seek export licenses to sell two types
of high-end chips the a100 and the
upcoming h100 and any future chips
equivalent in performance
these processors help accelerate the
most intensive parts of machine learning
used in ai in an scc filing nvidia
revealed that the us government fears
there is a risk that the products may be
used in or diverted to a military and
use in china and russia both companies
do not currently sell to russia
nvidia statement indicates it does not
expect licenses to be granted in most
cases and could take a 400 million hit
this quarter
beijing is clearly not happy about the
restrictions a chinese foreign ministry
official said the us is trying to impose
a technological blockade on china and
that the restrictions show america is
trying to maintain its technological
hegemony reuters quoted the u.s
department of commerce as saying the
restrictions are meant to keep advanced
technologies out of the wrong hands
these restrictions come shortly after
the biden administration offered
billions in subsidies to a taiwanese
company if it agrees not to sell its
most advanced semiconductor chips to
china
taiwan semiconductor manufacturing
company makes the most advanced chips
for nearly every company on earth
including nvidia in amd
although tsmc has factories in china and
one in the us its most advanced
factories are in taiwan for security
reasons i did a video about the
importance of tsmc which i'll link in my
description
tsmc is now building a 12 billion dollar
factory in arizona so it's no surprise
that arizona's governor doug ducey is
the latest american politician to cozy
up to taiwan he flew there to meet with
taiwanese president tai engwin
not to mention in 2019 the trump
administration lobbied the dutch
government to block the shipment of
cutting-edge machines that are an
essential component in printing chips
for tsmc and other chip makers the dutch
firm asml is the only company in the
world making the 150 million dollar
machines that pattern the finest lines
on the most advanced ships
the biden administration has been
pushing asml to stop shipping even its
less sophisticated systems to china
which would seriously hurt chinese firms
that are producing their own
semiconductor chips
these new u.s restrictions involving
nvidia and amd are another attempt to
hamper china's technological
capabilities without integrated units
from these two companies chinese firms
will find it more difficult to implement
advanced computing for speech and image
recognition
these processes are commonly found in
smartphones for example for identifying
people in photos on your iphone
they also have military uses
such as scouring satellite imagery for
weapons or military bases
or listening to communications and
monitoring faces for intelligence
gathering purposes
washington has argued that products sold
in the chinese marketplace are ending up
in the hands of the chinese military
for example nvidia in intel sold ships
to sugan a chinese firm that makes
computers for various companies but also
supplies them to the chinese military a
report in 2020 by the new york times
raised concerns that these chips are
powering a supercomputing center that
conducts mass surveillance in china's
northwest xinjiang province to track
uighurs and other muslim minorities
both intel and nvidia told the times
they were unaware of what they called
the misuse of their technology
in 2016 a chinese police surveillance
project called sharp eyes had the
ambitious plan of being able to monitor
a hundred percent of all public spaces
in china by 2020 even the vast rural
areas
there is no word on how far they've come
in achieving this goal
although the blockade is meant to
prevent american technology from being
used by america's military rival ai
chips have wide applications companies
like alibaba baidu and tencit use them
in their data centers to process large
volumes of data
now they'll have to make do with lower
performance gpus that could slow them
down
so there are broader implications for
society
or perhaps it is inevitable that china
will begin producing its own high-end
gpus and become self-reliant
it may only be a matter of time
the people who are shaping our future
have a deep understanding of how the
world works which is why brushing up on
your math science and computer science
skills is essential that's why i trust
brilliant which helps you improve your
stem skills through learning
interactively i know my viewers
especially love their computer science
fundamentals course in this course you
have to deliver mail to every house on
the street using as few commands as
possible
you can solve puzzles with science
through their scientific thinking course
or practice everyday math by seeing
numbers in a new light there's something
for everyone for me i'm continuing to
enjoy their logic courses which are
helping to improve my critical thinking
skills
there are no tests in brilliantness for
people of all experience levels whether
you're a student or already working it's
free for you to try out if you head to
the custom link in my description
brilliant.org slash newsthink and the
first 200 people who sign up with my
link will get 20 off brilliant annual
premium subscription which gives you
access to all of the offerings including
the most advanced courses
thanks so much for watching for
newsthink i'm cindy palm